was geht hier soll max und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video
heute spielen wir mal wieder lametta und
zusammen mit - du richtig guter ruf
leute wir haben wieder was neues am
start und zwar ein richtig richtig coole
stadler wie erstmal wir haben noch
andere maps sind leider noch nicht ganz
eingerichtet das ganze wurde von team
fand ausgebaut vielen vielen dank dafür
ich castus aber sie stellen hier ich
habe der mann schwer
bin auf jeden fall hier auf der
torwartposition schon die bessere
rüstung
das spiel startet gleich leute wir
spielen erst mal noch auf der alten
karte beim würde ich sagen starten wir
einfach wie gehabt drei zwei eins klar
gaga und ich hab schon zehn statt
vielleicht geschieht ja wirklich geht
mal zu franz die grünen schafften die
kommentiert franz focken hacker
ich dachte das weißt du ich hab dich mit
einer hexe verwechselten dieses über
hessens verwechselt krankhafter mit hexe
youtube beginnt 200.000 abonnenten im
monat sollte akkus difficulty nach dem
titel sind ja mach einfach an dem
schüler hoch ich bleib so lange stehen
bleibt lange stehen pflanze die ich war
heute stehen in der zeit so dass du in
der zeit halt tippen kannst und ich
machte auch nicht weiter in der 2
du bist wunderschön ein wunderbares das
ist eine liebeserklärung hast du uns
bayerischer ich hab ja drei stück gar
kein ich habe sieben normale bis zum 5
jeder normale neuen normale praxen bis
heute richtig wird der sonne 17
lucky blogs bekomme ich einen spray
normalerweise ist das immer so
einigermaßen balance aber so kann dass
er sein mit lucky blöcken manchmal hast
du lachst du kannst du bist so ein
richtiges lukas podolskis ihre zitate
öffentlich ich habe jetzt einfach
rechnungsprüfern war ich glaube dass
balsam galten oder lieber doch
düsseldorf 3 das glaube ich auch franz
da gebe ich dir auf jeden fall recht
nicht ganz uneingeschränkt aber doch ja
wir sollten also regenerationsprogramm
ich glaube diesmal schafft ich mag keine
sorgen mache ich habe inzwischen wie
viel habe ich habe 32 alte 31 blöcke
hast du ja ich hab 31 blöcke in lucky
day
ich habe 21 stück nicht
ich fange mal mit den normalen dann habe
ich so erwartungsmanagement da kommt es
bei mir aus ich komme wie auch die
bauern ruf als ganz bekommt leute ist es
so schlimm diese widgets nerv mir so
unendlich bei den kickers
diese diese hexe macht so aggressiv das
nächste bekommen ja kann ich nur sagen
hh hier kommt schon lasst mich in ruhe
hexe bitte man die karte sieht schon
wieder aus hier ja ich hab da guckt
bekommen dankeschön dafür auf jeden fall
noch länger
alter schwede mit der gleicher ich habe
gerade ich habe ein item bekommen das
hat einen richtig dicken effekt glaube
leute ich habe etwas verbessert was
schickes bekommen beide gesetze ist okay
lass ich hab ich aber sicher was ich
hier noch scharf am start ist
ich dachte das ist okay als claassen
beide geht's weiter geht's doch auch mal
reichlich
so weitergeht steht dass da und
sarkasmus zu bekommen bisher noch kaum
ich habe kein einziges rüstungsteile
bekommen echt nicht ich muss mir jetzt
ein bisschen was klar wenn mich
verarschen ich am richtigen bogen aber
er stimmt nicht ich kann mich auch noch
ein bisschen rüsten körper eigentlich
franz bin ich schon so weit rallye
festival soll ich nicht gut finde ich ok
franz ich hier eigentlich bereit
ich bin dann bin ich ab
ich bin in dem kreis drin geht man bloß
wegen los geht's jetzt los und du wirst
nicht kämpfen können ich finde ganz viel
glück
denkst du oder was so was hast du gesagt
hast du gesagt was war das ich hab ganz
viel dem tisch platziert dann hab ich ne
granate aus dem tgv und bin weggerannt
ja das center hat mich sicher getötet es
war die granate dem motto alter ist
yaman ich hatte auch den ganzen scheiß
hatte auf diese news unsicher die kübel
wecken können ich hatte
ich war richtig gut man hätte wills
letzter zeit war es irgendwie immer so
dass wir direkt im deathmatch irgendwie
durch in kleinen dummen fehler gestorben
sind oder weil einfach der andere
irgendwas im kassenbuch gezogen hat aber
ich befürchte so so ist einfach lucky
jetta und wir hatten jetzt aber bei
franz offen sehr ausgeglichenen kann in
einer folge lucky blog race und da haben
wir irgendwie auch dieselben
voraussetzungen von könnte ich auch in
zukunft ausgerichtete kämpfe freuen die
überlegung ein bisschen was kann auch
gerne was die kommentare schreiben und
passt das
es ist eine zutiefst und sie heißt maut
was sie erlebt hat hat sie etwa etwas
mit dem mord zu tun mit dem aufmarsch
der bald erscheint um mein gott auf
markt.de homo das war gerade eine sehr
subtile art und weise vor zu betreiben
nein wir machen was mit march und es
wird in kassel zu tun haben ist also
wenn ihr mehr informationen wollte noch
mehr luft vorbei aber guckt auch für
franz vorbei weil bei den gags oft
wieder lucky gibt okay leute das war's
von heute zwar kugel oder am 8
bis zum nächsten mal